لقد انتهى جائحة الفيروس التاجي ولكن المعركة ضد الفيروس لم تكتمل، انظر هنا معنا، وسيتعين علينا الاستمرار في التعايش معه، كما نرغب في دخول المستشفيات والوفيات في ارتفاع خلال الأشهر القليلة الماضية وفقًا للدكتور. ماندي كوهين، المدير الجديد لمراكز السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها، هذه هي الخطوة الأولى للتأكد من أن نظام المناعة لديك قوي قدر الإمكان، وينصح مسؤولو مراكز السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها الناس بالبقاء على اطلاع دائم باللقاحات المرغوبة لتحسين التهوية الداخلية. لإجراء الاختبار عند الاقتضاء والبقاء في المنزل أثناء المرض طالما أننا نستخدم هذه الطبقات من الأدوات. أعتقد أننا في وضع أفضل مما كنا عليه قبل كبار السن والأشخاص الذين يعانون من ضعف الصحة قد يرغبون في التفكير في ارتداء قناع أثناء وجودهم في الأماكن العامة أنا لا أتحدث عن إلزام أي شيء، بل أتحدث عن الفطرة السليمة واتباع التوصيات التي من المحتمل أن نحصل عليها من مركز السيطرة على الأمراض مع تقدمنا ​​في الخريف، وإذا زادت الحالات في عددها، فإن مركز السيطرة على الأمراض يشجع البلاد أيضًا على احصل على لقاح الأنفلونزا هذا الخريف تقول حملتها الإعلانية الجديدة إن لقاح الأنفلونزا يمكن أن يحول الفيروس من حالة برية إلى خفيفة، أنا جون لورانس أبلغ عن أمر مذهل